marta tiene un presupuesto fijo de 20
pesos y lo gasta todo en dos bienes
equis y el precio de x es cuatro pesos
por unidad y el precio de g es dos pesos
por unidad la siguiente tabla muestra la
ganancia total medida en pesos que
recibe marta de su consumo de cada bien
cuál es la ganancia marginal de la
quinta unidad del bien x para marta para
responder a esta pregunta
veamos ella obtiene 40 pesos de ganancia
total cuando compra 4 unidades de equis
y cuando ella pasa a la quinta unidad
tiene una ganancia de un peso adicional
pasa de 40 pesos a 41 pesos por lo que
la ganancia marginal de la quinta unidad
es ese peso extra
esta es la ganancia marginal un peso
calcula el total del excedente del
consumidor y martha consume cinco
unidades de x el excedente del
consumidor es la ganancia menos el costo
que va a ser igual a cuando ella tiene 5
unidades su ganancia total es de 41
pesos y cuál es el costo de 5 unidades
de x x cuesta 4 pesos por unidad 5 por 4
es
pesos así que el costo es 20 pesos el
excedente del consumidor es igual a 41
menos 20 es 21 pesos actualmente marta
consume 4 unidades de equis y dos
unidades de y usa el análisis marginal
para explicar por qué esta combinación
no es óptima para marta pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responder a esto
primero veamos cuál es la ganancia
marginal por cada unidad adicional de x
hodei y después veamos cuál es la
ganancia marginal por peso vamos a
agregar columnas extras esta es para la
ganancia marginal de x y esta para la
ganancia marginal de james y las ponemos
en esta tabla para ahorrar espacio
la ganancia marginal de la primera
unidad es 16 ya que pasamos de 0 a 16
para la segunda unidad pasamos de 16 a
28 por lo que tenemos 12 pesos de 28 a
36 son 8 pesos de 36 a 40 son 4 pesos y
de 40 a 41 es un peso de ganancia
marginal ahora hagamos lo mismo para y
para la primera unidad tenemos 10 pesos
de ganancia
para la segunda la ganancia total
aumenta 8 pesos la siguiente unidad pasa
de 18 a 24 por lo que tiene 6 pesos de
beneficio de 24 a 28 hay 4 pesos y de 28
a 32 pesos de ganancia marginal con esta
información podemos calcular la ganancia
marginal de x para el precio de x y
también la ganancia marginal de yep para
el precio de g
comencemos con las primeras unidades
para la primera unidad tomamos la
ganancia marginal de x y la dividimos
entre el costo por unidad de x 16 pesos
entre 4 pesos es igual a 412 entre 4 es
38 entre 4 es 24 entre 4 es 1 y 1 entre
40 puntos 25 para ello tenemos que una
unidad de cuesta 2 pesos así que la
ganancia marginal por peso de la primera
unidad es 10 pesos entre 2 pesos que es
igual a 5 pesos 8 entre 2 es 46 entre 12
es 34 entre 2 es dos y 2 entre 2 es 1
ahora analicemos cuál sería una
combinación óptima para marta cuando
ella piensa en gastarse sus primeros
pesos obtendrá una mayor ganancia
marginal por peso si compra una unidad
de jet así que comenzamos aquí después
vemos que la ganancia marginal de la
segunda unidad de ge es la misma que la
primera unidad de x así que marta es
indiferente por lo que podría comprar
ambas en cualquier orden puede comprar
esta primero y después esta otra aunque
puede hacerlo en distinto orden hasta el
momento ella ha gastado dos pesos más
dos pesos más cuatro pesos ha gastado
ocho pesos de un presupuesto de 20 pesos
después vemos que la ganancia marginal
por peso de la siguiente unidad
adicional de x es igual a la de ella si
analizamos lo que menciona el inciso c
ella ya compró dos unidades de iu y para
darle el beneficio de la duda digamos
que ahora ella compra una unidad
adicional de x pero una vez que ya tiene
dos unidades de ambos bienes y ella aún
no se ha gastado todo su presupuesto
solamente ha gastado ocho aquí y aquí
son cuatro lo que da 12 pesos por lo que
puede gastar 8 pesos más el siguiente
paso lógico sería que como la ganancia
marginal por peso que tiene la siguiente
unidad de iu es mayor que la de la
tercera unidad adicional de x lo óptimo
sería comprar una tercera unidad de ge
pero en el inciso se dice que ella sólo
tiene dos unidades de james y es por eso
que nos damos cuenta que esta
combinación no es la combinación óptima
para marta escribimos cuando ella tiene
solamente dos unidades de la ganancia
marginal de y entre el precio de y es
mayor que la ganancia marginal de x
entre el precio de x para la tercera
unidad así que ella debería comprar más
de dos unidades de ella
cuál es la combinación óptima de marta
para los bienes xy ya iniciamos este
análisis aquí hasta el momento ella ha
gastado 6 pesos más 8 pesos así que aún
le quedan 6 pesos para gastar
ella es indiferente en cuanto a la
siguiente unidad adicional de ambos
bienes
quizá compra otra y con esto gasta 8
pesos más 8 pesos le quedan 4 pesos para
gastar por lo que compra otra equis y
con esto se acaba su presupuesto gastó
12 pesos aquí y 8 pesos acá ella compró
tres equis y cuatro jets esta es la
combinación óptima indica si alguna de
las siguientes opciones hace que la
cantidad óptima del bien y aumente
disminuya o permanezca igual pausa en el
vídeo y responde a esta pregunta
el precio del bien que se duplica si el
precio de yeah se duplica entonces la
ganancia marginal por precio de iu va a
disminuir ella va a obtener una menor
ganancia marginal con jeff así que va a
comprar menos de ella el ingreso de
marca disminuye a 10 pesos y los precios
no cambian si recordamos el ejercicio
que acabamos de hacer el presupuesto se
acabará antes por lo que definitivamente
disminuiría la cantidad de ellos que va
a comprar el ingreso de marta se duplica
y el precio de ambos bienes se duplica
también en este caso las cosas
permanecen igual porque ella puede
comprar las mismas cosas
aunque cueste en el doble porque su
presupuesto también se ha duplicado así
que compra las mismas cantidades de
equis y y todo permanece igual nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo